où est le machin pour mettre les maires
et on n'a pas et serait tu as payé
quatre honda 1000 $ pour cette caisse et
il ya même pas habituel pour mettre mon
père non je les payais 800 mille dollars
et y'a pas plus rapides comme bagnole de
série sur cette plaine de 0,1 temps en 4
seconde édition limitée très cher aux ja
les limites et c'est le mot ya rien pour
les mères ya pas de banquette arrière
c'est rien qu'une but en or avec de 16
mois et nous les deux co couilles dahan
traînent par terre à chaque fois
en perte
des
solistes
mais toi remet regarde et je peux même
pas me blesser et demande sa mécanique
amitié je suis pas assez souple de
l'avant bras laissant toutes voiles
dehors dénichent robin
mexique les excités on n'est pas marié
ok c'est pas moi de nettoyer ta garde ma
main quoi je peux rien faire là je suis
coincé tu veux que je te dise si je la
resort tu sais comment on m'appellera le
capitaine crochet non ramasse moi c'est
très bien mais faire un policier on
mange pas de prix normal de toute façon
moi j'y vais jamais dans les fastes les
petits coups rapides c'est pas trop mon
truc ils ont mordu yapluka l'affairé et
tu t'emballes ans patrick à la con 6-7-8
utah qui reste avec des cendres la mer
ouais mais gare on n'a pas joué de la
semaine alors sortez ces bagnoles
d'accord incroyable tu peux conclure sur
81 kg et tire toi de mon soleil qui fait
eclipse avec ton gros tu descends
déborder moi le gros lard de service et
à chaque fois pourquoi aller descendez
d'accord d'accord d'accord on est mon
pied
est marrant c'est kate d'asnières comme
vous qui ont vraiment pas de pot dans là
dit il savait que vous êtes en train de
braquer des flics away et moi je suis un
vrai comique et cherchiez besoin de ta
bagnole écoute je suis par wesley snipes
je faisais juste un tour avec le prince
des connards dans sa bagnole de connards
qui attire l'attention des fils de [__]
de votre genre tous ses coins j'ai bien
envie de venir te [__] mon point sur
laquelle espèce de tekna on en fait une
montagne pour une misérable fric de
nerfs winfried mais pour ton manque de
respect pour la propriété prêt
on gueule c'est des conneries c'est
stupide en voulant bella alors tu veux
qu'on s'est battu pour que la foule
comme ça wesley snipes passagers 57
maintenant tu vas me faire le ménage la
lessive
oui toi fait moins marrer le comique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
des chauffeurs
[Musique]
oui
elle
[Musique]
je suis de la police c'est cool vous
êtes super
[Musique]
tu vois tu peux compter sur moi
c'est combien ça 12 $ s'il vous plaît
alors j'ai oublié mon portefeuille
quelque part casey's bonne de malda
surtout ne bougez pas je suis pas dans
ce coup là j'y comprends rien la fièvre
est ma parole tu attires la violence et
les arbres peu la ferme je te bute
calmez vous d'accord nous sommes des
officiers de police vous n'êtes pas des
flics ne sont pas débiles qui me connaît
attendions attendait de genève des flics
je vais vous montrer mon un signe
d'accord dans la série main si tu veux
que je t'en vends des espèces de merde
je m en tiens c'est un dollar un signe
allez je te l'avais dit que ça
marcherait pas le coup d'oeil jeté la
foux dans le quai et toi aussi ce
théâtre dans lequel rappelle j'en ai
plein le cul et depuis assez longtemps
fait pas le malin toi j'en ai très bien
d'autres et j'ai c'est un tracteur est
on si tu veux qu'on baise [__] on est
en cours lancé karim wade bull a
vraiment bouleversée je prends cette
histoire au sérieux tu sais en fait moi
et ce fumier on n'a pas de même idéal et
voilà à quoi ça bête tout ça passe à
autre chose mon prochain des tas de
choses qu'on prend toi rédaction il a
l'air décidé
mais moi je me casse ça se ferait sans
faux plis sale [__]
et un sweat baiser à les poses ton arme
après ça recul toit et filmant un paquet
de chewing gum ont repris la passion et
de la guimauve
h fais moi plaisir shop le fils de [__]
qui m'attire excès c'est sur moi qui
l'attirait je lis ça va bien j'ai servi
de balle en votre ami rouge estime sauf
mais je m'en tire pas la
taxe locale qui tape julie tirs sur
madame on va le mettre aux pièces ont
pas le mettre en pièces
moi j'ai juste un truc à dire mon pote
et dégueulasse tu m'as laissé pis elle
s'en fait c'est la patte de qui est
intéressé mais il la ferme pour le
moment il conduit
devrait tirer plus souvent dessus ça
améliore t'a conduit
le droit d'observer le silence
tout ce que vous direz sera utilisé
contre vous au tribunal mais qu'est ce
que tu racontes là je gagne du temps mon
frère
[Musique]
sa case et plus rapide y a pas plus
rapide et toute façon la plus le choix
nous élus et qu'est ce que cous et 3
qu'elle ouvre
se cachent pas qu'ils vont le mieux
qu'on passe
le montant
[Musique]
que c'est comme ça qu'il faut que tu
conduisent alors maintenant c'est comme
ça que je veux que tu t'en 10
pas un geste
oui ils méritent pas qu'on le but
le jeu
[Musique]
bush et si paris quand réveillant ce
matin aux [__] tu t'imagines est pas
claire ce hacker aurait un trou dans la
zone
a les couilles la trouille je pourrais
encore crois pas que ce soit fini je
faisais une pause
je commence à croire que je serai un bon
sniper dans mon genre
et dans le dos d'un mec qui courent à 50
mètres ça n'a rien de drôle c'est comme
ça que c'est marrant à bout portant
c'est beaucoup plus intime mec comme ça
je prends mon pied
tu pourrais le faire mike laisse tomber
c'est là
[Musique]
allez c'est terminé
c'est un clown
c'est qu'un port of war est le
clou
[Musique]